اكثر من 78 عاما منذ تاسيس جامعه الدول
العربيه عشرات القمم عقدت ومئات القرارات
اتخذها القاده العرب تاريخ طويل واحداث
مفصليه عصفت بالدول العربيه جمعت قادتها
حول الطاوله ما بين اجتماعات عاديه واخرى
استثنائيه اولى القمم الرسميه قمه القاهره
في العام
شكلت نقطه تحول في مسيره العمل العربي
المشترك حيث اكتسبت الصفه الرسميه للقمم
العربيه وشددت في قراراتها على اهميه
تنقيه الاجواء العربيه من الخلافات
جاءت القمه العربيه العاديه الرابعه التي
عقدت في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
العام
1967 بعدها هزيمه عام 67 او ما عرفت
بالنكسه وفي اكتوبر من العام
عقدت القمه السداسيه في الرياض بدعوه من
السعوديه بحثت الحرب الاهليه في لبنان
ودعت الى وقف لاطلاق النار وتطبيق اتفاق
القاهره
قمه اخرى ايضا في العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
في العام
1987 دان العرب خلالها احتلال ايران اراضي
العراق واعلنوا التضامن الكامل معه للدفاع
عن ارضه وسيادته
وخلال اغسطس عام 1990 عقدت في القاهره قمه
طارئه بسبب الغزو العراقي للكويت خرجت
بقرارات تاريخيه منها ادانه العدوان
العراقي وعدم الاعتراف بقرار ضم الكويت
ومطالبه العراق بسحب قواته فورا
وبسبب العراق ايضا عقدت القمه العربيه في
العام 2003 في شرم الشيخ بمصر حيث اكدت
رفضها المطلق لضرب العراق او تهديد امن
وسلامه اي دوله عربيه
وفي القمه العربيه التي عقدت بشرم الشيخ
بمصر في العام 2015
اكدت ايضا في قرارتها على دعم الحكومه
الشرعيه في اليمن ومساندتها
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات